[Applause]
[Music]
the garment industry is broken people
would be shocked if they saw what goes
on in their factories it really changes
the way you think about clothing when
you consider the people in the process
but because there is no visibility when
you buy Garner's
you are just oblivious to it the Rana
Plaza complex which housed a textile
factory collapsed last week killing 400
rescue workers in the Bangladeshi
capital Dhaka continuing to hunt for
survivors
today's disaster is unlikely to slow a
booming industry which thrives on the
world's lowest labor costs when
factories collapse we hear about it when
factory fires kill workers we hear about
it the grinding long days the
difficulties they face we don't hear
about that it touches something we don't
want to talk about a lot which is poorly
paid people living in places where they
don't have a lot of opportunity that's a
hard subject to talk about
the root of the problem is corporate
greed it's companies trying to maximize
profit by selling as much or as little
as possible to consumers who are willing
to buy those products more and more
Americans are awakening to the reality
that there are responsible sustainable
alternatives to sweatshop products your
purchasing decisions can affect the
lives of workers around the world we
look at fair trade as the first step in
a very long journey towards getting wage
equity in the supply chain
[Music]
even if the non-canon sound money doubt
begin about a nun but I'm animating a
hard-on only mama picture mother shiny
mom belong in the mannequin and if I'm
born in Omaha with a child at a vice or
Bupa high heart rate an agate you know I
don't negative love Maleeva muna hodella
[Music]
buying in one of their barbecue today no
no fancy teletransport a game
[Music]
[Music]
then in bed of about arrogance to take I
go to Baba a dollar
[Music]
my name is Chameli Silva I'm the general
manager of Heidemann inhaler we are
making mainly tops jackets t-shirts
pants we are unloading the fabric is
from the fabric supply that's from
Taiwan this will spread the fabric they
will drive the cutter to the design so
after cutting it will be numbered and
then it will be inspected there are a
thousand four hundred people working in
my factory it's about 70% women and
about 22% men in spite is one person
will be doing only one operation
see check the Garmon relate is good or
that 98.8% is good at the end of the
line barton box with completed goods
Wow so there are a lot of factories out
there that do an amazing job right now
the problem is that those factories that
are performing in a more sustainable
level simply don't have an effective way
to compete with the bottom feeders with
the bad factories bad labor practices
look pretty much the same a common theme
is bad treatment of workers low wages
unsafe factories and pollution of the
environment around those factories we
live in the age of globalization farmers
and factory workers around the world are
going to be plugged into the global
market in one way or another and so for
me the question is are they victims of
the global market or are they being
included in the benefits of
globalization fair trade in the garment
industry the fairly new concepts
typically it's associated with other
products like chocolate tea and coffee
for a factory to become Fairtrade
certified the factory works hard towards
meeting Fairtrade standards when brands
joined the program they agree to pay a
premium on top of the cost of the item
the good news is those workers receive
that money directly it doesn't even go
through management the workers set up
their own bank account they manage those
funds directly they get to vote on
whether or not to distribute that money
as a bonus or start a a scholarship
program or build a daycare center
we are working with about eight breaths
in this Miele Factory Patagonia where
the one and only plan approved for fair
trade so we learned about the fair trade
and then we discuss what disease what
are the benefits what is the purpose
impression was really super-nice Kemeny
Maharaja muna have been making the Quran
Nakia Nakia we met here with the
employee council and one of the most
most important proposal was the dakea I
can remember the day I went to see the
daycare because one of the happiest
moments in my life I mean it was amazing
you know I saw the laughter I saw the
smiles more than anyone mothers were
really happy they can concentrate on
work because they know that they are
children and safe fans
baba tikka college but it in the value
none and Aki god I'm the Catena darling
I never to read it didn't wanna give it
[Music]
the industry has an opportunity to take
a stance and try to provide a better
more positive way of living for a lot of
people around the world we have to prove
the business case for Responsible
business if it's just a philanthropic or
a philosophical endeavor
it won't scale we have to prove that
fair trade is good for business
Patagonia is really ramping up our
program quickly in fall 14 we had 11
Fairtrade certified styles in fall 16
we're gonna be at 200 and in fall 17
we're gonna be at 300 styles and that's
30% of our product line
[Music]
we envision farmers and workers becoming
architects of their own future
we're helping workers not just improve
their lives but also find their voice
the results go way beyond just $30,000 a
year to this factory or a 50,000 to that
factory and the projects that they do
with that but underneath that and above
that is this invisible dividend from
fair trade and it's all about hope and
pride and dignity and self-confidence
[Music]
Taman even say everywhere they got you
to powder my Arctic you got an anaconda
would have Malika you know anything
[Music]
when I go into the fly
but a 14-year veteran
yeah hopper to be a table on that the
opinion villa
after the mo yeah oh mama you look about
a Forester
yeah the DVD a piano here near market my
heart it ain't nothing but mobile app or
a tornado in a world where two billion
people live on $2 a day we clearly have
our work cut out for us
I think it's really easy for people to
forget that there are people behind
everything that we buy in the supply
chain that hands actually touch it
we're not just here to make a product
it's about sending a message to the
world that eventually no factory has
workers that are exploited I mean this
just should not be tolerated in this day
and age we need to keep the pressure on
so that every brand is doing this we
just want to sweep the effects of
focused consumption under the carpet and
we can because we don't have to think
about it that's invisible story behind
products that we buy we have to keep
asking the hard questions and challenge
ourselves there's an easy route and
there's a harder route that involves
doing the right thing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]